I want you to think about this you're in
your entire lifetime how much money has
gone through your hands how much let me
explain to you what I mean by this maybe
you make seventy three thousand dollars
last year twenty eight years old and the
first time you got to check with
fourteen years old it was a hundred
dollars add that whole thing up you'll
come out with a number four hundred and
ninety three thousand dollars or 1.9
million dollars or six point three
million dollars depending on who it is
watching this video the question is this
how much is left in your wallet truly
what is in your wallet not what's in
your wallet with capital choice I'm
talking like really what's in your
wallet what do you have left how much
savings do you have left and if you're
not too happy with this question it's
very simple
the reason why you don't have a lot of
money left is because you don't know how
to play the money game simple as that so
today in this video I'm gonna cover with
you 20 rules of money these are rules of
money that I followed and it's obvious
people in a lot of mistakes I know
because it was a point in my life where
I had made money there was nothing left
in my pocket
some telling me from experiences but
rule number one is the most important
one and it's the one you have to buy
into immediately it's very simple you
can fight it say whatever you want to do
to it it's a rule and the rule is it's a
game
money is a game and the great thing
about any game is the following thing no
matter what game you play the most
eventually get good at it if I've never
played chess and I play you and you
played a hundred times chest you're
probably going to beat me if I have
played Monopoly a thousand times and you
play three times I'm probably going to
beat you because it's a game so the
great thing about the money game is it
can be learned so many times people
fight it and they have problems with it
and they said well you know it's with
that person became rich because they're
smart this person did it son no no they
learn the game and you can also take the
time to learn the game rule number two
is don't be a hater of money if you hate
money you'll never get money because
money doesn't like haters so if you're a
hater and you can't see say things like
wow money doesn't grow on trees and
money is this and money is that and rich
people are this you're right money says
you're right I'm not turned on by you
it's almost as if going on a date with
an attractive girl and telling the girl
that
you don't like attractive girls who
don't know a lot about philosophy and
all they care about is very looks and
doing makeup and doing this and working
out and go to the gym and this goes like
did I put makeup on I work out every day
to stay in shape but I also like other
things in my life but you know what
you're right you're not attracted to me
I don't like you she goes and finds
another guy that says I like a girl that
takes care of her body I like a girl
that takes care of her skin I like a
girl that does makeup I like a girl that
works top-five this week she's attracted
to that guy keep that part of mine don't
be a hater with money number three it's
a doubles game listen this should pretty
you can stop watching the entire video
you got the main things out of the way
it's a double game and by the way at the
end of the video I'm gonna give you a
free pdf it's a double game what is a
double game the entire game of money
it's about doubling your money so what
do you mean doubling your money let me
explain it to you this way if you right
now have a thousand dollars in your bank
account if you you're watching it you
have a thousand dollars cash you are 10
doubles away from a million dollars
that's it you're five doubles the way
from having thirty two thousand dollars
you're 13 doubles away from having 8.19
two million dollars you're 14 doubles
away from sixteen million dollars it's a
double skinned so how soon can you
double your money that's truly the game
can you take that thousand dollars and
double it to two thousand dollars in the
next year so then that next thing is
now it's two thousand dollars you have
an account now you are nine steps away
from a million dollars you make a pad
already have a hundred thousand dollars
in my account well guess what you're
four doubles three Devils away from a
million dollars all you got it's a
doubles game this is a piece of cake
when you'll learn its a doubles game so
the question that becomes what how soon
this is this is the real game of doubles
it becomes two different things risk
tolerance because you got to know your
stuff when it comes to money your risk
tolerance depending on the age you're at
if you're 65 your risk patterns going to
be lower than you be in twenty two years
old right so you have your risk
tolerance you need to know you then the
other part is time horizon what is your
time horizon so time horizon could be I
want to have a million dollars buy a ten
years from that great if it's ten years
what do you have right now then you have
to play your doubles game how many
doubles do I have with the $17,000 to
get to a million bucks
it's a simple game that you can learn
what to do as long as you know your risk
tolerance you know your time a horizon
what it is and what the amount is then
you're playing the doubles game number
four seduction let me explain to our
seduction okay listen I use the analogy
with ladies because it's just how it is
okay money likes to be seduced money is
attracted to seducers it just like a
woman doesn't like a desperate man money
doesn't like desperate people money's
not attracted to desperate people who
want it so bad because they want to make
this money show it off to everybody you
know money seduce you need to seduce
money seduce money and all of a sudden
money says oh I like this guy I like
this girl oh my gosh I'm turned on to
you don't let money seduce you you
seduce money it's a seduction game so
whoever learns the seduction game with
money all of a sudden money starts
coming from all over the place to you
because money is turned on by people
that know exactly what they're doing
money like investors who know what
they're doing okay a girl goes on a date
with a guy that knows what he's doing
she's most likely to come back and then
there's experience learn how to seduce
money once you learn this whole thing
you'll get better at this game as well
it makes timing a timing when it comes
down to money let me explain about
timing I'm not talking timing like this
is the best time to mess into snapchat
or this is the best time to buy the IPO
of Facebook and etc I'm not talking that
timing although that's a whole different
conversation with timing timing I'm
talking about running a business
I'll give you an idea there was a time
where logically I have to cut down okay
in my business and I have to get rid of
two or three employees logically I have
to cut down but I knew what I was
getting ready to do a night I had access
to all the information I decided to
double down and that helped expand the
business to new area news new
territories so and then the other part
is cutting down expenses as you know ink
may be numbers are looking very good but
there's an area that needs to be cut
down that no one else knows about the
information you need to cut down because
you have access to all the information
so there's got to be a part where you
need
knowing that this is a thing that we can
teach you this is not something I can
teach you about but this is going to be
a part of it you're going to learn from
an experience with timing timing with
when you buy timing on when you invest
timing on when you stay light timing on
when you stay liquid timing on when you
go there's a timing aspect all those
decisions you'll make number six boredom
it makes no what board means money needs
to be moved okay
again if a girl is bored with you she
leaves you because you're too boring
same with man if a man is bored with a
girl they're going to leave because it's
boring money doesn't like to be bored
what do I mean if money stays in a
checking account money's going to
somebody else who knows how to use that
money if money is just staying somewhere
and it's not working it's too boring
it goes to somebody else that knows what
to do with money so you got to make sure
money's always moving money's always
moving for you always moving for you
always moving for you always working for
you always that they're doing something
to create more money for you next secret
account you always got to have a secret
economy clear with a sequin the counters
it's an account that no one knows about
your wife your husband your boyfriend
girlfriend mom dad brother sister no one
knows about this account what is this
account it's a crisis account a crisis
account could be cash of crisis account
could be somewhere sitting down that no
one knows when I know you make some time
you just thought well boredom you talk
about this two complete different
stories you've got to have a crisis
account that's not your emergency fund
I'm not talking emergency fund that this
is the right thing to do I'm talking to
crisis account what saved the business
when we were going through difficult
times and our company's checking account
went to $13,000 I have payroll
commissions everything $13,000 where
we're about to shut down the company
it's this quote we're about to shut down
the company what saved us was the crisis
account that I had no one knew but that
money showed up put it back into the
business saved us we lasted we made it
through the tough times and now we're
here where we are today but it's because
they had a secret crisis account no one
else knew but you always did have a
secret credit crisis got number eight
don't drive first class until you have
ten million dollars in the bank account
I see so many people spending two grand
on a flight where they can spend $400
listen I'm 64 65 240 and you know how
many times to fill out paper first class
zero I don't pay first class
other people pay for my first class but
out on papers class I've been paid first
class type form first class many many
times because I have the miles or people
pay for my flight I don't pay first
class and why is that here's how we did
the math now obviously I can afford to
do it no problem but here's how I did
the math you're trying to tell me two
thousand dollars for a first-class
flight and I can get five hundred
dollars for the same flight that's
fifteen hundred dollars ten to nine
flights in a month
that's ninth out thats you know nine
times what $1,500 is thirteen thousand
five hundred dollars some number like
that you know what I can do with that
number
that's for employees that's marketing
that's expansion there's a debt over a
year that's $200,000 hundred eighty
thousand dollars why I'm not going to
waste that money that's an executive I
can bring it that's two incredible
employees that can bring it I don't pay
first class other people pay first class
once you get 10 million bucks and you
want to do it that's great at that point
you may want to get yourself a private
jet but don't fly first class next comp
plan
let me explain to what I mean by comp
plan so no matter what country you live
in
ok I get emails from a hundred plus
countries around the world and some of
you guys and I talk through your
communistic system how you're upset and
you ask me what to do and I tell you if
it's not going to change you have to
leave you have to leave a communist
regime you're part of some of your own
socialistic places France taxes Spain
you're upset with the taxes being out
where it's at and I tell you if you
don't see the horizon changing you need
to adjust but regardless of where you're
at rule number one about your comp plan
your comp plan or whatever country you
live in is your taxes study how you get
tax because that's your comp plan and
let me explain to why the comp plan in
America does so well a lot of people say
things like this they'll say you know
what I can't believe the tax structure
in America benefits business owners and
you know why is it that they benefit
business owners because business owners
create jobs if you created jobs would
give you a tax benefit if there wasn't a
tax benefit and incentive for business
owners then who's going to create jobs
for all these millions of people that
need jobs so you may say well Pat if the
incentives for business owners should
not be a business on it yes you every
single episodes about you becoming an
entrepreneur
yes you ought to be a business owner you
ought to be an entrepreneur because it
benefits you in your comp plan it
benefits you in your comp plan and
position yourself properly by knowing
what your
planet rule number 10 end of the world
mentality
listen CNN MSNBC Fox suze orman Dave
Ramsey whatever these names you want to
go through all of these names put them
all together you know what they get paid
to do they get paid to sell crisis
because if it happens you've got to be
ready for it okay and so what happens a
lot of times is people get afraid and
they think it's the end of the world and
like their 2008 when the market crisis
took place the market went all the way
down to 6,000 some now Jones did
everybody started pulling their money
out it's at $21,000 today 21,000 points
to the imagine if you left the money in
how much compounding money was lost
simply because you thought it was the
end of the world simply because you
thought there was a nuclear world that
was going to happen all over the world
by the way let me explain to you if
truly a nuclear war is going to happen
do you really think your money matters
come on we're not going to exist so you
got to act as if there's no nuclear war
that's going to take place and panic so
much what everybody tells you everything
and you got to learn how to manage those
times when 90% of the world thinks it's
the end of the world you got to be ready
so how do you do that let me explain I
was part of the community that that it's
always the end of the world until I
realized how you become wealthy is
during this time during this time when
it's the end of the world you know who
wins those who have cash this is why
it's important to have cash set aside
and I'm not talking bored of money I'm
talking cash set aside when it's the end
of the world for you to buy stuff every
time crisis takes place a lot of people
become wealthy a lot of people who come
wealthy because everything's on sale
everything's on sale when there's crisis
people sell their exotics because they
can't afford it people sell their arts
work for one-fifth of a price home sell
for one half of a price investments all
these things is for sale during the time
when there's the end of the world end of
the world type of mentality so you've
got to have a strategy for this time
some say market is about to tank again
the next two three years I don't know if
it is going to tank in the next 2-3
years here's what I do know it's going
to tank in the next 20 years and I'm
ready for it I have to be ready for it
because there's going to be
opportunities you also got to be ready
for
number eleven study your politicians
especially your president let me explain
to you why you got to know what your
politician and your local community is
going to do what their philosophies are
here's why you need to know their
philosophies if their philosophy is to
do heavy-duty taxing on you you need to
adjust accordingly if their philosophy
is to cut down taxes you need to adjust
accordingly people ask me Pat what am I
going to do with Trump start a business
taxes are being cut go make your
millions of dollars the next four years
and if it's eight years go make your
money and adjust everything is about
adjustment but you can't not know what
their philosophies are you need to know
the philosophies of the pilot
politicians in your community number
twelve study smart investors but don't
be too religious about them like for
instance you ought to read everything
Warren Buffett's got read every single
thing Warren Buffett's got every single
thing read any of the books that he's
got go read them because what he's going
to teach you is his way of thinking his
mindset he's going to teach you to
wasting like some people said why did
Warren Buffett spend thirty five million
dollars to buy silver six years ago and
why did he all of it so why does he not
do any technology and stays away with it
you know why does he these are
philosophies the thing that you gotta
respect about Warren Buffett when he
says I don't do technology he didn't do
technology so he stuck to philosophy
long enough until it worked
study smart investors number thirteen
play your game
don't compare let me explain this is
extremely problematic to a lot of people
because let's just say on this doubles
game you're here and let's just say your
cousin is here why are you comparing
yourself to them you need to play your
doubles game let's say you're here let's
say your best friend is here it's not
the same game he's four doubles ahead of
you it's not two thinking you just got
to make sure you play your game you
can't say I'm going to play my game at
the level of what the other guys are
because when you do it that way you make
reckless decisions and you lose a double
you don't want to lose doubles you want
to gain doubles I don't know if I hope
I'm making sense to you you don't want
to go backwards and any time you focus
on this guy you sometimes go backwards
focus on your game focus on your
strategies focus on your time horizon
focus on your risk tolerance and play
according to that game your vision may
not need to be a billionaire your vision
may not be to go out there and do
something very big your vision may not
be to be a person that's got
50 million bucks your vision may not be
to the exact billionaire your vision may
be I want to one day have two million
dollars that's all good play to that
game and put a plan next to it place it
again but don't con to compare yourself
to other people okay
next index a lot of people say well as
long as you beat the index okay as long
as you beat the index I am more
concerned of beating my goals than I am
about beating beating the index I'm not
worried about beating the index and what
about beating my goals what is my goal
what is the deadline I want to beat that
number because it's mind that's what I'm
committed to what is my deadline I'm
committed to this I'm not committed to
the index I'm committed to this maybe I
need to do a lot more than what the
index is doing because this is why I'm
in business in business I can control
the amount of growth I want half of my
income I can control if I'm studying
just the index and index is going 11.9%
I beat a 20.3% but that's going to take
me a long time for me to get over here
no no play your game beat your goals
instead of trying to beat the index only
15 the friend moneymakers I'll tell you
why different moneymakers that you trust
if you run other people that know how to
make money you're gonna make money which
is kind of how things work out if you're
on people that know how to make money
you're generally going to make money if
you're around people that don't even
know how to make money or don't even
make a lot of money you're not going to
make a lot of money you know so so know
who you're going into business we know
who you're doing things that sometimes
things seems too sweet or sexy and all
this stuff but you don't know the person
I don't touch any of that stuff it's
important for me to know who I'm going
to be doing business with I hire very
slowly very slow the moment I'm done
with somebody boom gone for people we
employ in a fire in a date no problem I
can't do this the tolerance is not in
the right place we can't do this we need
to move on but I hire slowly especially
the higher up it is the more I travel
with the person to get to know them
same exact thing when it comes down to
here who are we going to do business
will befriend them travel with them if
somebody's extremely wealthy go to
dinner with them get to know their wife
see how they are under kids kind of see
their standards of living see their
discipline see their behavior and then
say I like this person I like what their
friends say about Amalekites cousin - I
like house this is a person I can do
money and business with number 16
diversification is for absolute sissies
okay so if you're a and your risk
tolerance is very low it's okay it's
okay to be a lot of people are
but if you truly want to create wealth
and you're wondering why in your
lifetime you've worked for 17 years and
you don't have a single penny and you
made six hundred and seventeen thousand
dollars yet you only have six six
thousand dollars to show for there's a
problem there there's a problem there
what is the problem
diversification is a great concept to
sell for these expert financial advisors
that are playing every single thing safe
and all these other things yes now for
those of you that are watching this and
you're 73 years old diversification may
be good for you if you already have hit
your goal of six million dollars in your
were your app we were 62 years old I
respect the fact that you've already hit
your numbers that solid risk tolerance
lower time horizon lower okay you're
playing a different game I'm talking
mainly to for the people that are in the
offensive motor deverel are their lives
that you're trying to get here maybe
you're around this market I'm not
talking to the people that are here I'm
talking to the people that are here
you're trying to get your doubles to go
quickly it's faster if you just rely on
diversification 20 30 40 years whether
you just got to know that's going to
take 40 years going to take 30 years
maybe that's if everything goes the way
it's supposed to be going so I don't
recommend just relying on
diversification to take you to where you
want to get to 17 the game is about
leverage everything that's leverage now
that explained what leverage means I'm
not saying leverage go into debt with
everything I'm not talking leverage like
that I'm talking leverage curry what
could leverage be leveraged your
business how can you grow your business
if you're running a business how can you
leverage to have more support how can
you leverage to sell more how can you
leverage to expand more how can you
leverage to increase the value of
business more how can you leverage to
market yourself more how can you
leverage to get to the customer fast
right can you leverage to increase the
speed of growth in your business how can
you leverage to get certain things going
how can you leverage everything is a
leverage game everything is a leverage
game and the more you study the concept
of leverage and the game how it works
the better it is for your world number
18 positioning positioning has to do
with for instance I'll say what
positioning is we can do a whole thing
on positioning but I'm just going to
give it in a shorter sense positioning
if I'm going to go work at a company and
I'm going to have a piece of the equity
and I'm going to position myself to own
a piece of that company it's going to go
public
that's smart positioning that's a very
very smart positioning
Tom over here who's our president Tom
created his wealth by positioning he
went in positioning himself in certain
places and participated in the victory
by owning a piece and he positioned
himself sometimes it's positioning
sometimes it's who you're running with a
lot of times she goes a lot you know
yeah I'm making great income with this
company I met yeah but you haven't
position yourself here because there's
no back end on the equity so it's
positioning you got also positioned
yourself here to make sure you're taking
care that part right of course you got
to take you your credit your going to
high income savings investments but you
got to make sure you position yourself
properly as well number 19 strategic
partnership strategic partnerships the
more you can create an environment it's
kind of similar to different moneymakers
but this is slightly different because
it's intentional if you can figure like
what we do with our company is we have
strategic partnerships where a lot of
people make money okay
the more people make money the more
people continue to do business with you
if there's strategic partnerships I have
strategic partnerships with 400 billion
dollar companies 200 billion dollar
companies 60 billion dollar companies AB
strategic partnerships with a lot of
different companies that benefits them
okay strategic partnership increases the
value of making money because a lot more
people are making money with you when
they go into business with you last but
not least big check syndrome let me tell
with the big check syndrome is oh my
gosh I've seen so many people screw this
whole thing up and I'll just explain to
what it is so for instance saying you
are doing a real estate hypothetically
okay and all of a sudden you get this
one clients wants you to sell their home
it's a three million dollar home I'm
just throwing numbers out there and you
go and sell this three million dollar
home and the check is 100 some thousand
dollars that you get and you say oh my
gosh I made a hundred thousand dollars
and for two months you live as if you
made a hundred thousand dollars in a
month which you don't realize is that
hundred thousand AutoCheck in a month
you need to look at it as an eighty
three hundred dollar a month income for
that year that's what that means it's
not a hundred thousand dollars and I've
seen so many people who treat this as
one hundred thousand dollars in a month
and they get cocky arrogance all this
stuff and then they go back to right
here and they're double goes lower and
lower and lower
and they don't realize it's just a big
payday let me explain would you rather
have right now a half a million dollar
cash I give you watch this question you
can answer would you rather take a half
a million dollars okay given to you
upfront imma give you half a million
dollars or would you rather take an
income stream guaranteed okay of
$100,000 over 20 years which one would
you take half a million up front
you take you know what believe it or not
most people will say well I think the
right answer is $100,000 most people
would take the half a million let me
tell you why the $100,000 allows you to
do more $100,000 is 2 million bucks the
half a million dollars is a half a
million bucks see this gives me the
opportunity to have a stronger backing
to make bigger decisions to get bigger
doubles now you may say Pat but half a
million dollars that already puts me
here it's irrelevant if you don't know
how to play the money game it's
irrelevant you don't how to play the
money game
I want high-income as well I want income
coming in that feeds my game so I can
increase my net worth this is a very
very important game so don't get too
crazy about big check syndrome and all
of a sudden fall for it and lose
everything that you got because it can
totally mess up with your network and
you work all the way back to your
doubles so with that being said this is
what I'm going to do to you
this episode is obviously an episode
that people would want to look at on a
PDF so we're going to give you a free
pdf but this is what you need to do you
need to visit Patrick gray David calm
we'll put the link on the bottom of the
YouTube video as well so you can see it
but if you're not here and you're seeing
this video on a completed front place
because videos nowadays are being shared
everywhere you can go to Patrick play
David calm okay when you go to the
website the link for this is going to be
there look for the link and if you don't
see it anywhere just go on the search on
the bottom of my website Paul show
exactly where the search would be type
in money and this would come up rules of
money this would come up and get the
free pdf print it out and look at it and
start studying which of those 20 rules
you following you do very well at and
which you don't and start adjusting to
it and study the areas that you need to
do to improve in those games so with
that being said if you have any
questions any thoughts any comments
comment on the
and thanks for watching everybody take
care bye bye
hey thanks for watching this video let
me make a case - I believe you need to
subscribe to value Taemin also join the
notification squad look there's two ways
you can learn about business wonder ways
go to college learn a bunch of theories
by professors who I probably never ran a
business before or you can watch value
tainment ran by entrepreneurs who have
built and sold businesses and you can
learn from our mistakes and what we did
right and by the way I'm willing to bet
anybody who goes and takes this boring
route verses watches value tainment
I'm putting my money this person watches
value Tim is going to beat the person
who goes to college you don't believe me
test me on this this is why I'm so
certain you need to subscribe to value
tainment and learn the content so you
can also be successful
[Music]
you